bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
oggi andiamo avanti con mezzo fa abbiamo
eravamo rimasti raga che se mi ricordo
bene avevamo liberato gollum una specie
di mostro che aveva ucciso vecchietto
vanta povero vecchie veramente mi
dispiace tantissimo che era lì che
indica la strada come un idiota
eva è morto vabbè pazienza e vabbè dai a
parte la morte le vecchiette anche mi
pare che si cela la chiave nel sì mi
avete detto che devo prendere la chiave
nel cesto l'ho capito che devo prenderla
ma se questa va la schizzinosa come
cazzola prendo c'è lei non vuol prendere
la chiave d'accesso perché non vuole
ficcare il marino eccesso mi sembra
giusta ma allora come il gatto le aprole
forte mi avete me l'avete detto perché
se non avrei mai fatto
mi avete detto che praticamente ecco qui
ci siamo
il corpo questo che mi segue in teoria
non mi sta stuprando ma sta cercando
effettivamente la testa che chiede a
guarire sbarre
e questo il corpo prendi lo prendi lo
prendi l'ho ce l'ho fatta
raga tra occhi e teste praticamente e
tipo i modellini dei lego ragazzi
possono montare c'è una roba usa e getta
cvt le teste prego prego non c'è di che
veramente
mi dai una gemma perfetto grazie va bene
era che abbiamo liberato un tipo senza
testa va bene
[Musica]
cosa ho fatto cos'è ma [ __ ] e due
ore che girava un [ __ ] va da sé ma
cazzo
forse posso prendere la merda nel cesso
credo di sì non possono nascondere gli
oggetti così cazzo c'è ma porca [ __ ]
va bè ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta dalla
ci siamo
possiamo andare a prendere la chiave
senza che ti schifi porca [ __ ]
ok va bene allora si cerca gatto mezzo
mondo lì dentro non me ne frega un cazzo
prendi st chiave ok c'è già l'abbiamo
fatta se rusty cage a via raga è un
miracolo c'e veramente si sono appena di
merda infatti però vabbè è tra l'altro
c'è ancora delle forbici in mano cioè
che cazzo devo fare l'acqua e nel
secchio ok ed evo a pulisci la chiave
che è fantastico devo pure sarà piena di
merda va bene
puliamo la chiave di merda e vabbè ci
siamo ragazzi ci siamo
non chiedetemi come può esserci né chi è
che la cagata st chiave poi va bene ogni
porta rusty chiede ce l'abbiamo fatta
possiamo dio deve vani ok raga io c'ho
la moto spi taglione brutto stronzo
pervertito che vuoi toccarmi il pesto
brutto la star di pesto
ok bene ci sono i ragazzi sono i
pervertiti quell'amico dello slider che
tentano di stuprarmi ma non ce la fanno
perfetto ci siamo adesso che abbiamo sta
male detto a chiare dobbiamo cercare di
aprire le porte ce ne sono un casino
adesso non so che è perfetto da questa
ce n'erano un casino invece chi è quello
buongiorno ok basta viaccia ricetto di
brutto perfetto allora non puoi passare
mi spiace invece vi tirate è stata la
porta vuoi qualcosa magari ti porta uno
snack telo patti passa un tweak
satanasso le sbarre
cosa vuoi va bene 96 li fa quello che
cazzo vuoi
a questa sia aperta maledizione c'è un
barile in mezzo ai [ __ ] sì l'ho
notato c'è una chiave li raga devo
raggiungere la chiave
c'è una spaccatura nel muro la vedo di
qua ci è possibile probabilmente raga
devo cercare di raggirare sta roba
sfondando il muro in qualche modo forse
magari mi faccio io viaggi mentali però
vabbè io tentano di farlo più avanti
alla tanto che questa si apre non c'è
nulla qui dentro però cosa ci devo fare
qui niente c'è water water vuoto devo
sfondare devo cercare di arrivare altra
parte la che in qualche modo farò
c'è una crepa nel muro c'è una crepa nel
muro allora prima di andare nella crepa
raga che mi sembra abbastanza voi la
voglio provare a vedere cosa c'è di qua
ok poi ancora più buio porca [ __ ] non
sapere niente cosa che cosa che posto è
questo
cos'è cos'è una chiesa all'interno ad
onna raga ma immenso c'è ma che cazzo di
casa c'hanno questi va bene è si è
chiusa la porta si è chiusa la porta
ragazzi è chiusa la porta si è permesso
mi offrite un tè una tazza di tè veloce
un caffè c'e nessuno questa è la stanza
dove mangiava c'è nel flashback dove
mangiava maria cioè la sala da pranzo
praticamente si è che cosa dovrei farci
evidente niente c'è ma voi vi spiegate
che cazzo c'entra una sala da pranzo
collegata con una chiesa nei sotterranei
non ha senso
tra l'altro qua c'è un pezzo di carne
cosa cazzo cedevo tagliarlo si posso
tagliarlo ho preso raga volete favorire
apre una macelleria se volete faccio
vendola carne così
va bene se c'è
c'è un corpo che c'è una padella raga
siamo in cucina
facciamo le crepes alla nutella ma cosa
devo fare cedevo frigi la carne sia i
fregi la regia frigida non so che
cazzola raga volete favorire non perché
qua stiamo cucinando è diventato cooking
mama va bene
ok siamo ai cotto alla perfezione la
mangiamo noi che dovevo farla maggio io
questa l'ho presa chiediamo a servire in
tavola che non c'è nessuno messore
proporrei un bel caviale dello chef bull
non vuole non c'è nessuno che vuole
favorire un caviale e allora mi spieghi
che cazzo braga ci sono rimasta un dio
mi hanno stupito di aiuto visto pero non
posso respirare
lasciami andare ok zeus mai no kat mai
ma allora lei cazzola procura dei mixer
ho vinto io
ok che cazzo mi rappresentava sta cosa
spiegato è vero che è un fantasma che ha
tentato di stuprargli ma non ci è
riuscito ok e probabilmente pervertito
con le mani di prima che allunga cosa
devo qualkosa è tutto nero adesso non
vedo niente si sentono dei parà spettate
che sento dei passi padre padre cosa
oddio mi sono risvegliato nella chiesa
sei arrivata anche tu
ma chi è questo cioè fatemi capire chi
cazzo ne so eun hee justin bieber è
quello del primo episodio
non ti preoccupare sono un tuo alleato
assicuro che non ci aveva l'occhio
fantastico sei sicuro di sé sono un
alleato perché non c'è l'occhio a me a
gente senza occhi non sta simpatica
scusami se primato solo intatta la mia
apparenza deve averti sorpreso sia
abbastanza non perché il genere non vado
in giro e vedo gente senza un occhio ma
vabbè
ok sì ci siamo quella quella benda sulla
tua faccia e se la linea padre non ti
preoccupare di questo è successo in
passato cerchiamo di uscire da qui
insieme si maraga non può in teoria non
si può perché c'è a lo tiene per mano
che carini va bene mai innamorarsi di un
fantasma o di un morto vivente twilight
insegna ai cans non posso perché non
puoi devo salvare mio padre o che questo
non la prenderà bene non andare non
andare ti prego ma non posso lasciare
papa ok la prende per mano questo ci al
vizio di prende la gente per mano
arrenditi con tuo padre
no devo salvarlo ok devi lasciare a mano
a edizione lasciami andare ascoltami
lei mi ha chiesto di fare questo lei mi
ha chiesto probabilmente parlerà della
madre sono sicuro ok oh cazzo è partito
un coltello l'ha preso no cazzo perché
chi è che ha lanciato il coltello
bastardi maria cosa si fa maria qui ma
non ci crede e sieri poteri farti cazzi
tuoi [ __ ] sai bene
no non sto bene mi hai ucciso il mio
amico maledizione maria maledetta
stronza di merda mi stai antipatica
perché non hai tentato di scappare
perché mio padre lascia il dottore a me
per favore avrai la mia parola che lo
riportano indietro per favore devi
trovare un posto sicuro ok intanto ha
calpestato tranquillamente il morto con
cui si va bene va bene così maria
lasciami venire con te si sentì
succedesse qualcosa al dottore si
arrabbierebbe ma mi sa che finisci ok
sia aperta di nuovo la porta cose perché
qualcuno voglia conoscermi
lasciami la sola cazzo no a non andare
di lava mio dio perché allora dimmi che
vivo ma non può morire un morto e già
morto cazzo mi metti l'altra band ha
semmai tanto noi sei bendato diventi una
mummia
dimmi che non sei morto ti prego mi sta
simpatico caso no perché
si muove porca [ __ ] ma perché perché
non ha dovuto missa sul culo maria
priest a porta a brutta stronza almeno
ti sei mangiato la carne che avevo preso
c'è ma fatemi capire qualche cosa c'è
prima che non ho capito
ok successo qualcosa questa cosa che è
successo o cazzo se ci sarà porta non si
apre più raga ce l'abbiamo leica pranzo
non si apre più la porta ok buongiorni
token tentato di stuprargli primavera
brutto bastardo
aprite z michael apri sfrutta porta di
mezza sfonda sbandati rara testate cazzo
ce l'abbiamo fatta
ok
abbiamo aperto la porta fantastico sì
non c'entro più lì dentro invece ci sono
rientrato e non c'è più
mister ha il professor letto il
passaggio era molto ostacolato malori
pulito un po
grazie mille professore vado a torni a
risolvere i suoi big mi va bene io vado
avanti sono mi spiegate perchè c'è
trunks è ma che cazzo sono manichini
raga ma che cazzo ci sono due stanze
uguali tra l'altro che sono identiche
che cosa devo fare qui cena professore
era andato di la prima dov'è che cosa
cazzo ci fa qui io appaio imposti
inaspettati sì me ne sono accorto basta
che non mi appari mentre dorme perché ti
scambio per lex luthor quindi è risolto
il passo per aprire questa porta quale
puzzle cioè che cosa dove di gioco è un
puzzle per che cazzo devo risolvere
spiegatemi la porta è bloccata
fermamente ok c'è un ok c'è devo
spostare re probabilmente devo metterlo
in una delle stanze lega non so ancora
quale e non so ancora in che modo
però devo metterla è che è successo ho
spostato un cavaliere le due stanze sono
molto simili però hanno delle differenze
allora innanzitutto tipo il cavaliere
quando nella lancia i fiori non si sono
il questo quadro è sporco si vede che
devo mettere le due stanze simili devo
ammetterlo uguali praticamente allora
questo la lancia da me la trump vi serve
ok grazie devo dare la lancia il
cavaliere perfetto devo mettere i fiori
ma i fiori dove cazzo sono vabbè devo
mettere i fiori sul vaso ma non c'ho i
fiori e il re dovrebbe andare tipo ii
cioè 18 come cazzo cosa devo fare
devo mettere il re questo posto ce l'ha
fatta è però mi manca una rai a mi
mancano i fiori i valori prendi pioli
così prendevo prenderli da piantano come
faccio devo prendere con la motosega
l'italia taglia vialetti fiori ok
evidentemente ha sì li ho presi cazzo
funziona ok non pensavo sinceramente
funziona se ce l'abbiamo fatta
devo metterli soltanto se riesco
perfetto c'è ce l'ho fatta maledetto con
sapida porta sia risolto ho risolto
brutto non solo di malori e sono uguali
le stanze non rompere la noce il
cavaliere che ancora la testa
oddio perché di là non ce l'ha la testa
giustamente come cazzo faccio se ha
funzionato
non ci credo va bene abbiamo staccato la
testa del re
ok adesso ci siamo non rompa aprì la
porta ci sono diversi misteri che
arriveranno sì mi fa piacere a fissa
casa ok perfetto ci siamo
bello fantastico la ricompensa giusta
per tutto il casino che ho fatto ma c'è
qualcosa sotto il tavolo qui lo vedo c'è
qualcosa di radio è caduta la testa del
re
ok senti io non cioè io l'ho tagliata
perché dovevo aprire la porta è io non
ho fatto un cazzo
c'è c'è la bibbia che cos'è il mio
diario perfetta diari di maria è sparito
diario raga è diventato chi è questo
dormito cullato vicino a mia madre è ok
oh cazzo c'è un bambino a una scuola
scultura di un bambina sono sculture
queste la scultura di una donna che è
abbassata sì
la carne non la posso servire perché
ancora non c'è
perché quel cazzo di a fare mi somiglia
buongiorno io gli ho preparato della
carne prima vuoi qualcosa da mangiare
ciò angri of a me va bene allora devo
ricordare a fare il buffon
devo riuscire a prendere devo portarli
sì cioè io l'ho preparato da mangiare è
spaccati st bistecca tieni quasi prendi
stabilità di camagna maglia che è tutta
salute
vorresti questo a profumo ha come la mia
carne preferita e magnate la che il caso
di devo dire a mi fa piacere che
gradisce ok ci siamo ma già tranquillo
così buona mi fa piacere
assomiglia a quella della mamma beh io o
tu non conosci le doti culinarie rifà vj
c'è ma scusami
vuoi mettere cazzo se la possibilità di
farci una crepe rega mi somiglia in una
maniera porca [ __ ] cioè che cazzo va
bene mi sembra un po alla capelli alla
yugi oh ma per il resto non è come i
miei come gli standard di mia madre ma
comunque era buonissima mi fa piacere
grazie mille
ok il punto esclamativo cosa è successo
che visto o questo lo sai cosa mi hai
dato
grazie per avermi dato del buon cibo non
ti preoccupare
niente per la prossima volta ti cucino
di nuovo ok ragazze ne è andato ho preso
un netbook in un tovagliolo che cazzo ci
faccio con un tovagliolo e vabbè
beh mi ci pulisco olè ho spinto il
bambino cazzo avevo fatto prima che non
c'ero riuscito va bene una madre e suo
figlio o dormono vicini ok perfetto
abbiamo sbloccato il passaggio c'è una
ma cazzo
cos'è successo hanno scortato un gatto
va bene ha ucciso un animale per
divertimento poi ci ho preso la mano c'è
sempre un gatto morto un uccello nella
mia morto nella mia stanza
mia madre è diventata pazza quando li ha
trovati quando mia madre e sceglie
nascondo i corpi dei cassetti cazzo ma
che schifo ma perché devi nascondere la
canon ci avrà mai un senso sto gioco va
bene ed evo spingerti cosa devo fare qui
quando hai dove nascondere il corpo nei
cassetti allora si vede che devo
nasconderlo dami corpo ho preso un gatto
morto e l'avvento nel cassetto
ok e adesso che devo fare devo aspettare
di a questo è l'altro uccello ma
nascondiamo tutto nei cassetti
cioè eliminiamo le prove c'è soltanto
una chiazza di sangue nel tran nel letto
almeno che non hai avuto le mestruazioni
è un po difficile che la passi liscia va
beh non importa cosa devo fare
ti metto sopra magari così la nascondono
e cosa dovrei fare devo spingere la
madre fuori non ho capito
stavano fuori di cosine fa ok ce l'ho
fatta
ok ci siamo ok perfetto allora andiamo
avanti
ok ragazze come cazzo è che la cosa
diventa sempre più macabra mia madre ha
trovato mi ha trovato mentre io ho
ucciso gli animali mi ha sgridato sta
zitta ho ucciso mia madre con un
coltello
ma cosa mia madre caduta tuta sporca di
rosso di sangue non sembrava verso una
bella faccia quindi era tagliata male
cozza ma cos'è sta merda casa faccia
morta sembrava veramente fantastica
similia bene sei un poeta nato cazzo
devo la mamma è collassata co sangue mi
fa piacere
sei un pazzo maniaco o che deve essere
deve essere mio padre era piccolo quello
cioè vabbè ho preso un coltello
non farò una cosa del genere non ci
credo che poi farlo a dai ma non ci va
bene al massimo taglio te brutto
bastardo di me cosa vuoi fare con quel
coltello a ammazza c'è fai quello che
vuoi ma non mi toccare invece devo
spingerci verso la mamma devo mettere
mica alto vaglio a ok tovagliolo serviva
questo ma devo pulire la faccia che è
fantastico e tipo il parabrezza quando
fai la polizia della macchina fi
grazie mille che ci abbiamo fatto se ok
adesso ha dato a scortare alla casta è
diventato c'è questo qui mica è sta
diventando jack lo squartatore ucciso
mia madre della spaventata ed ero
spaventato e sono corso via oltreoceano
volevo dimenticare tutto ma non poteva
dimenticare la mia bellissima la
bellissima faccia di mia madre morta
così decisa un'altra e sono rimasto si
va bene non ci ho preso la mano e vi
piaceva vedere le palle facce della
gente morta
raga è traumatizzante suo gioco
veramente mi mette di buon umore cazzo è
morto mi fa piacere che è morto cazzo
per la ragazza sembra spaventata si che
ci credo porca [ __ ] cioè soltanto una
falce e si ti taglio la faccia porca
[ __ ]
non volevo rai a un disastro non poteva
tagliamo la faccia a tutti ma non posso
passare perfetto e grazie mille
ho tagliato la faccia a mezzo mondo va
bene raga siamo passati oltre rega e
trauma del ragazzo gioca veramente
assurdo io la voglio finire qui per
questo episodio per oggi è tutto sei
video è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi
piace anche alla pagina di facebook che
come in ogni video sto cercando
telecomando non lo trovo trovata anche
la pagina di facebook come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione ne ho fatto
una finale di merda va bene lo rifaccio
non mi ricorda e matt father che mi fa
andare a [ __ ] il cervello non è colpa
mia se mi dove piaciuto lasciato un
commento vi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete turisti
scrivete indici vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazza